the story of a talented young chef whose
career is absolutely sizzling thanks in
part to a super bowl sized opportunity
kayla greer or chef kk has cooked her
way into the kitchens of some of
california's biggest stars and the
hottest sports bar in west hollywood
and she can trace much of her success to
a single game day decision to take a
chance on herself for our series the
dish lilia luciano spent some time with
the chef and enjoyed some of her
scrumptious celebrity approved dishes
for football fans
it's the most wonderful time of the year
we are making vegan nachos for kayla
greer also known as chef kk the super
bowl is all about the food i mean
honestly like
look at that looks so good you know why
i'm so calm because i know i'm about to
bury my face into these in about two
minutes the chef who has found her way
into the kitchens of celebrities
throughout l.a works with vips like demi
lovato 2020's super bowl performer and
ellie rams star linebacker von miller
this super bowl is crazy i cannot
believe that los angeles has a stadium
for one like we have a team we have a
stadium it's a whole thing it's
happening for those without a private
chef grier created a simple spread that
anyone can whip up at home i would think
of like shareable things things that you
can just pick at with your hands finger
food yeah you can get really creative
with nachos you can make shrimp nachos
crab nachos you can do vegan nachos it's
very colorful and vibrant and it's
everything that you want on one platter
i would also go for like sandwich type
of things so you can do maybe some
grilled cheese sandwiches or
chicken parmesan sliders so when i think
football i do think wings grier grew up
in south central los angeles and would
rise early to take the 5 a.m bus to
culinary school a decade ago she
received a message from a music producer
friend that would change the course of
her career it was so crazy i just got a
call the day before super bowl they were
like are you available for super bowl
tomorrow and i was like yeah they're
like okay it's for drake i was like
okay cool yeah i'm available were you
sitting very casually i couldn't believe
it as soon as i held that phone i was
hopping up and down i could not but it
happened so fast i mean from that phone
call i probably didn't sleep for the
next 48 hours for someone living in a
studio apartment with only a small
kitchenette at the time catering a large
party at the home of a superstar was a
game changer for the rookie chef towards
the end when it kind of started dying
down he came in the kitchen and we just
started talking i'm like i'm eager i'm
young i'm hungry i'm just like do you
have a chef
you know i'm just like griers saw an
opening and ran with it she worked with
drake for years and even went on tour
with him but you know what my favorite
part of that story that happened because
you asked them do you have a private
chef
so many people don't take that step
that's such an important lesson you
never know i mean when an opportunity is
there you have to take it you know and
you have to realize that you may not get
this chance again you have to make sure
that you go above and beyond because it
can either be the gateway to your next
one or it could be your last
you know i don't know if it's the
truffle honey but i just got chills
rare ingredients and raw talent drove
the la native from the start when did
you decide that you wanted to be a chef
i had a lot of different jobs in high
school just stayed busy i just felt like
you know what i could become a private
chef i was naturally great at cooking
i'm really tall so i started cooking
younger probably even a lot of people as
soon as you could reach as soon as i
could reach the stove i was like
scrambling eggs for chef kk nothing
seems out of reach these days i only
had a plan to become a private chef and
that has taken me further than i ever
would have imagined with her growing
roster of clients and her duties as the
executive chef at west hollywood's 40
love sports bar grier's plate is full
what was drake's favorite any of these
guys
definitely had the buffalo chicken on
there i mean that's a staple leave no
chip behind
none it's been a quite a journey
and a reminder that hard work sprinkled
with a little luck can be a powerful
recipe for success
for cbs mornings i'm lilia luciano in
los angeles
[Music]
nachos anyone ah really good i will
point out and i applaud this that the
guacamole clearly had no tomatoes in it
i'm a no tomato guacamole guy yeah it's
again a thicker guacamole um also
interesting that lily is there she's
working right that's an interview she's
on the job but she was eating that you
have to yeah you have to how do you not
and i do love what she said there though
that it's the opportunity when you have
that opportunity you never know is it
your next opportunity or is that your
last